been like playing this much Zone this
season this much zone defense I feel
like maybe the team you played the most
Zone with um you know it's just you know
you have to switch up pitches you have
to change things you know defens is
offens is so um so good now that they're
able to if you show them the same you
know steady diet of you know plays
whatever they they'll you know they'll
get a rhythm for that so um it's good
pull it
sorry pull it shoot it oh good pass
catch the ball man how shoot it how was
Bonnie looking in that game um he's
doing well how's USC looking they've
been better they're down
well of our beats what have you seen out
of 80 with the passing the last few
games triple double in Utah almost had a
triple yeah he's he's learning from me
how to pass out of the
post that's what I'm seeing I'm serious
he's working on it and it's great team's
gonna stop doubling him soon long as we
make shots out there for him shoot it
um long as we make shots for him then
you know teams will stop doubling them
so it's it's it's our it's our job to
make sure we in the right position shoot
it um it's our it's our job to make sure
we're in the right position at the right
time when he gets doubled we have a
numbers game it's going to be a four on
three on the back side so we had to put
ourselves in position when it was 16 to
you guys went on a 16 to4 run in the
third quarter in a tight game what you
like in that period third defensively we
were in tune and then offensively we're
really intact God sorry that's right
wide open layup um defensively we're in
tune with our game plan and um and then
offensively we did not turn the ball
over and when we don't turn the ball
over we clean glass defensively we are a
really really good team um we have high
turnover games and we give up a lot of
offensive rebounds we're the complete
opposite so what's tougher uh losing a
tough game or watching your son play
college basketball when they're
struggling
um uh watching college basketball alone
is tough
and then you add my son in there it's
even this yeah yeah cuz you know I'm
it's hard to watch it's hard to watch CU
you're a dad not just yeah I'm a dad but
also love the game of basketball and
college basketball just every it's like
10 people in the paint at the same time
it's it's very hard at times to watch
but USC is a good great program Arizona
is a great program so it's you get a get
an opportunity to watch some good
basketball in this game appreciate it
what have you seen from B these last two
weeks and does it kind of show what you
guys were missing
I mean just his his activity Alone um it
just helps our ball club and um you know
when he's active like he's active and
only you know let's let us know that
he's getting healthier and healthier I
mean that heel has been kicking his butt
from the beginning of the season but
he's starting to get more and more
healthier and you can see just his quick
twitch you see his his ability to to
finish and transition now his ability to
you know um just do the things that he's
capable of doing rebounding defending
picking up people full court changing
directions you can't do none of that
with a bad heel I don't know if you guys
ever had any foot problems and then try
to play sports with it It's just tough
so you know he's just getting he's
getting back in back in a V uh shape and
his foot is feeling a lot better I think
I think he can tell y'all for sure but I
think